certains psychologues disent que l'envié
la peur mon père bon je ne suis pas
psychologue vous rassure je suis
navigateur professionnel mon métier
depuis plus de 25 ans c'est de mener le
plus vite possible en double ou en
équipage
les bateaux les plus rapides sur des
compétitions océanique transat jacques
vabre 2005
c'est une course en double deux par
bateau départ du havre
arrivé à bahia au brésil
franck cammas et moi prenons le départ
nous avions déjà gagné sept précédentes
éditions en 2003 mais là nous partons
avec un trimaran de toute nouvelle
génération
fraîchement sorti de chantier à peine
rodez le bateau s'appelle groupama 2 dès
le départ les conditions sont difficiles
coup devant grosse mer très humide mais
notre duo fonctionne bien on prend la
tête de la course
cette bonne heure puis péripéties
technique on descend la troisième place
ça va encore
troisième jour de course la nuit tombe
je suis à la barre depuis plus d'une
heure à pleine vitesse et en un éclair
le bateau bascule le nez plonge dans la
mer
l'arrière où je suis assise et catapulté
sur la vente
je m'accroche m'agrippe ou filet comme
je peux le mât de 30 mètres se fracasse
sur la mer le choc si violent
marage du filet et je fais une chute de
18 mètres de haut dans l'inconnu et fini
sous l'eau sous l'eau et sous le bateau
renversé sur ma tête qu'ils m'empêchent
de remonter là ça va moins bien et me
demandez pas de vous raconter ma chute
la nature est tellement bien fait que
dans le moment le plus terrible
j'ai perdu connaissance
dès que je reviens à moi coincé sous le
filet d'apatou de 5 tonnes je cherche
comme un fou une porte de sortie
hélas oui j'ai eu peur j'ai peur mais là
tout était présent alors l'instinct de
survie bien sûr mais les préparations
les stages de survie tout ce que j'ai
appris
jusqu'à maintenant est présent prem
servir en lattes me retrouvé sous l'eau
évitez les obstacles et cordages les
voiles les câbles qui entravent la
progression vers l'avant du bateau
remonter à tout prix sur la coque
retournée rejoindre la coque centrale
renversé mais au moins au chaud dès que
je suis à l'abri la douleur le sur mer
je ne sais pas encore mais j'ai six
côtes de casser et que certaines
indélicate avait fortement endommagé mes
poumons
je n'ai plus que 30 % de capacité
respiratoire
c'est la limite de la survie et le
médecin espagnol qui veut gentiment me
l'expliquer ne parlant pas anglais et
moi pas espagnol j'ai rien compris
et là c'est facile de n'avoir même pas
peur le pire dans les situations
dangereuses
c'est pas le danger c'est d'être
tétanisé paralysés par la peur quand il
faut agir
tous les métiers comporte des risques
les nôtres sont spectaculaires mais
d'autres plus discrets sont pas moins
dangereux vous aurez peur c'est
inévitable moi ce qui m'a sauvé c'est la
préparation aux risques on peut pas tout
prévoir mais on peut minimiser les
risques en s'entraînant comme dans le
sport de haut niveau comme dans la
musique comme dans la danse
l'idée
c'est de vraiment s'entraîner à quelque
chose qu'on ne veut pas vivre pour y
survivre
si ça arrive alors moi j'ai eu peur mais
sans doute moins que franck cammas qui
était avec moi sur le bateau
il m'a cherchée du regard après le
chavirage et me trouve pas fou il amer
de la nuit tombante et sait qu'il lui
reste très peu de temps avant de plus
rien voir ne pouvoir rien faire
cet épisode reste dit il
la plume peur de 52,7 carrière pour moi
je suis navigateur c'est mon métier
alors il faut y retourner et la caisse
qui permet de surmonter la peur
engendrée
j'avoue dire c'est l'équipe
on était deux sur le bateau est derrière
un projet comme groupama
il ya toute une équipe à terre l'équipe
de david o nous avons pu échanger par
les débris fait comprendre être compris
de fait que tout ce travail collectif
nous a permis de reprendre très
rapidement la navigation d'abord très
des côtes puis au large 2008 tentative
de record du tour du monde en équipage
le trophée jules verne franck cammas oui
navigateur et moi prenons le départ
nouveau bateau groupama 3 c'est 31
mètres de long 22 mètres de large
bien plus grand qu'un terrain de tennis
plus grand qu'un terrain de basket c'est
41 m demare soit l'équivalent d'un
immeuble de 14 étages
nous sommes lancés en pleine vitesse
dans le pacifique sud et là de manière
totalement imprévue le bateau se
disloque sous nos pieds en 20 petites
secondes le bateau et d'un amas de
carbone est pourtant là nous n'avons pas
eu peur maintenant dans une eau à 4
degrés il faut réagir vite et grâce à la
préparation
chacun savait ce qu'il avait à faire et
il l'a fait le bateau était disloquée
par le web mais nous avons eu de la
chance parce que déjà il faisait beau on
est et on habitait près des côtes de la
nouvelle-zélande qui nous a permis de
secourir rapidement le sponsor a tout de
suite réagi on répare et un repas
curieusement c'est un équipage plutôt
aux fabriques qui est monté dans l'avion
pour paris a à nouveau peur que ça
recommence
oui cela ne pousse à nous entraîner à
nous préparer encore plus et d'être d'un
sérieux absolu dans des domaines comme
la sécurité
l'anticipation permet à chacun de mieux
se préparer aux défis de faire face à
l'inconnu et n'a prévu elle permet aussi
de minimiser le facteur risque
le stress l'anxiété et nous permet aussi
de contenir et surmonter les peurs
j'ai heureusement au logiquement je ne
sais pas mais cet accident à souder
l'équipe
elle nous a rendu plus fort
l'équipe a reconstruit bateau un an plus
tard il repartait est rentré vainqueur
du trophée jules verne
mais laissez moi vous raconter la plus
grosse peur de ma vie je suis un
parisien de 20 ans à peine plus âgé que
vous je viens fille d'un des études de
commerce
tout était en place pour que je m'engage
jolie carrière en entreprise
mais j'ai une autre idée c'est une folie
une idée née sur des petits dériveurs
sur lequel j'ai navigué pendant les
vacances
dès l'âge de 5 ans j'aime naviguer
j'aime la compétition
vous allez me dire c'est un peu juste
pour entrevoir une carrière de
navigateur
et c'est pourtant ce que je veux faire
le service militaire obligatoire c'était
pas le permettait d'exercer comme
moniteur de voile mais ça ne suffit pas
j'en veux plus je veux naviguer sur les
océans en compétition j'en ai envie et
j'ai peur j'ai peur parce que pour y
arriver il n'y a pas de demi mesure il
faut multiplier les expériences en
compétition m'immerger dans le milieu de
la course au large
la ligue est avec les meilleurs laisser
mon diplôme de côté au risque de le voir
se déprécier
j'ai peur du vide j'ai peur de l'échec
peur du changement peur de ne pas faire
ce que les gens qui m'aiment attend de
moi peur qu'ils aient peut-être raison
être navigateur n'est peut-être pas un
métier que faire que choisir
peur ou pas peur j'ai choisi d'y aller
et pour ainsi dire j'y suis allée avec
ma peur est là une fois engagé j'ai eu
tellement à développer de travail de
rigueur d'obstination qui avait plus de
place pour la peur la peur elle nous
attend quelque soit notre parcours alors
autant que ça sur celui qu'on choisit
j'ai fait de la peur mon allié elle m'a
souvent protégés alors peut-être que le
plus important c'est de n'avoir même pas
peur de la merci
[Applaudissements]